hot breath how long did it take you to
find your voice
because what what i've as you're chewing
and i mean i've heard you say you
started out
experimenting you went like through a
stephen wright phase where you're very
deadpan then you went through a robin
williams phase where you're very
animated so like
through that process how long did it
take you to hone in and become
rich boss not rich he's definitely not
rich
but rich boss uh well you don't know how
rich i am i'm doing rich with regrets
uh i don't know i guess
as i progressed and got more sober
and got older and experienced more i
started
you know i'm still working on finding
out you know trying to be
i always try to get better and improve
you know and i want to be as honest as i
can
but i also look i do cry if i do crowd
work i
i don't do it as much as i used to
that's
not fun it's just being it's not finding
your voice it's just
doing crowd work which is as hard as any
some comments saying god i see it's hard
as
everything yeah to do good crowd work
big j is greater crowd work
oh my gosh the master no he's not the
master i'm the master you
i love i'll throw little jabs in there
you did that on purpose
and then just like hit like haymakers
you really think he's the master he's
great at it no he's really good
he's great at it i interviewed uh ian
bag on here about it too
he's great yeah and his system was like
you just have a conversation with the
people yeah you're not trying to set up
a joke
no you're just you're having a
conversation something will come out of
it
exactly yeah so a good crowd work guy
will
take everything in full circle and make
it into a story almost
you know big j ian
todd barry is good yeah
this whole comic jimmy brogan was good
from la and you know i was the best
and you're the best still the best